[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce set fit
invités nous sommes aujourd'hui le jeudi
11 mai 2017 et nous recevrons d'eux
invité jean-pierre fouilles au vice
président en charge du développement
durable à saint quentin en yvelines pour
parler d'environnement et du plan climat
air énergie territorial qui doit être
adopté au plus tard le 31 décembre 2018
déployés sur les douze communes
d'agglomération ce pca e t va définir
une stratégie et un plan d'action précis
une grande concertation numérique est
aussi lancé également en plateau
joël nizar vous êtes président de racine
club de généalogie qui fête ce week-end
ses trente ans de recherches et
d'entr'aide généalogique des exposants
des conférences et beaucoup de conseils
du côté d'el en cours avec joël nizar
nous allons à partir donc sur le chemin
de nos racines avec la jl généalogie
pardon mais tout de suite environnement
avec vous jean clair plus haut d'ici fin
2018 saint quentin en yvelines aura donc
son plan climat air énergie territorial
un outil qui est également une
obligation de la loire la loi grenelle 2
pour permettre de lutter et de s'adapter
aux changements climatiques à l'échelle
du territoire alors pourriez vous nous
parler de ce plan en quoi consiste-t-il
ce plan consiste à fixer les objectifs
stratégiques et opérationnelles pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
pour anticiper les impacts du changement
climatique et s'y adapter favoriser la
transition énergétique dans le cadre de
l'efficacité énergétique la sobriété
énergétique et des énergies
renouvelables et bien sûr améliorer la
qualité de l'air dès qu on a les quatre
objectifs
peut-on déjà d'ailleurs à propos de
qualité l'air et peut-on déjà mesurer
les impacts les bouleversements
climatiques sur l'agglomération
alors nous allons pouvoir le mesurer
puisque nous avions déjà élaboré un
premier plan en 2013 mais à l'échelle
des sept communes là on va le faire à
l'échelle des 12 ou non de lancer une
un questionnaire numérique pour un rock
les lire les avis des habitants juste
après donc avec ça nous pourrons
comparer les choses et voir comment ça
évolue
alors dans ce plan qui sera impliqué
dans ce plan dans ce pca a jeté les
entreprises les particuliers alors le
plan le pays s'est arrêté il y aura
l'aide de mes narration qui est un des
patrons ya fort avec des communes qui
connaît déjà bien leur territoire les
douze lagence locale de l'énergie et du
climat de saint quentin en yvelines
l'ademe le club climat énergie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
entreprises et institutions ainsi que
les acteurs locaux dimanche
l'observatoire du climat qui est à saint
quentin en yvelines
alors ce mois-ci voulons c'est cette
concertation donc nous avons lancé donc
là là
la consultation numérique les habitants
viennent sur le site de saint quentin en
yvelines et peuvent aller répondre aux
différentes questions qui leur sont
posées sur ce document ensuite cette
consultation va durer de mai à octobre
on fera un premier bilan atelier qui se
mettront en place avec d'une part les
élus au départ et des habitants ensuite
afin d'élaborer ensemble
ce plan qui définira des stratégies et
des obligations à faire sur les six ans
qui viennent
pourra-t-on connaître les résultats et
qu'on les résultats bien dès la fin pour
le le démarrage est ensuite au fur et à
mesure des années il ya un bilan qui
sera fait année par année pour voir si
on est dans les objectifs ou alors on va
revenir un petit peu sur ce pc a été
d'accord donc simplement est ce que vous
pourriez nous expliquer un petit peu ce
qui a déjà été fait par l'agglomération
de saint quentin est ce que ça va ce que
ça va changer
il ya déjà des engagements que
l'agglomération a pris par exemple
lorsqu'on est neuve des bâtiments
renforce l'isolation de faire les
économies énergétiques sur les bâtiments
ce que font également 6 déc hodler au
fond un équipement
nous avons pensé aussi avec le ps lui la
possibilité pour les entreprises de
faire lorsqu elle le souhaite la
construction en construction c'est à
dire éliminer les bâtiments qui datent
des années 70 et refaire des bâtiments
aux normes actuelles
c'est une opération tu vas être
entrepris d'ailleurs eu avec kim
l'international que nous avons vendu qui
va être détruit et reconstruit avec les
normes actuelles etc accueillant aussi
du logement
on sait que en ce qui concerne l'impact
carbone des activités des modes de vie
sur le territoire
un tiers des émissions et produit par le
transport des personnes est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui va au sens il ya déjà
eu des choses de faites puisqu'on a on
développe avec le service mobilité des
bocaux voiturage nous sommes en train de
mettre en place avec les entreprises
un plan qui permettra lorsque les
collaborateurs veulent aller à plusieurs
par exemple à l'aéroport d'orly ou de
roissy de regrouper deux sont regroupés
ensemble pour avoir un seul moyen de
transport tout ça c'est c'est sur les
rails avec le club climat énergie on va
pouvoir attaquer la première expérience
pour les entreprises enfin le qu'elles
sont quels sont les les entreprises
quelles sont les entreprises qui sont
concernés aujourd'hui par par ce plan
qui vont être jalouses toutes celles qui
le souhaitent une consultation qui a été
fait par le club qui m'a énergies et
toutes les entreprises qui souhaitent
aujourd'hui ça intéresse les plus gros
nous
bouygues mais c'est ouvert à toutes les
entreprises thales et airbus s'est
ouvert à toutes les envies
merci beaucoup monsieur jean pierre
guyot je rappelle donc ce plan climat
air énergie territorial pour 51 des
lignes d'ici 2018
et dès ce mois ci une grande
consultation donc sur votre site
internet
est-ce qu y point fr c'est simple
changement de sujet avec la généalogie
et joël izard vous êtes président de
racine un club de généalogie
alors simple première question comment
vient ton à s'intéresser à la
généalogique
comment bientôt à s'interroger à
s'intéresser à l'énergie c'est une très
bonne question ça dépend des personnes
se disent qu'ils vont vers ne vous qui
est pourquoi vous êtes vous intéressé à
la généalogie en ce qui concerne l'or
c'est le pur hasard mon épouse
lorsqu'elle était en activité voyager
beaucoup et à chaque fois on lui
demandait souvent niesr c'est mon nom
est un nom d'origine tunisienne
je disais je n'ai pas d'origine
tunisienne
bon c'est vrai c'est comme ça et quand
je suis parti à la retraite à me dit
maintenant tu as le temps
j'aimerais savoir comment cette
recherche je me suis fait tirer un peu
l'oreille finalement j'ai commencé et
j'ai pris goût pour un particulier quand
on ne connaît pas la généalogie comment
on commence ses recherches
la démarche normale c'est d'abord
d'interviewer ses parents proches dans
les personnes les plus anciennes de
manière récupérer le plus d'informations
parce que contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser ce n'est pas toujours les
informations des plus lointaines les
plus faciles obtenir les informations
récentes quelquefois peuvent poser
problème du fer du fait de la loi des
descendants des 75 ans on n'a pas accès
à tous les documents et en plus les
personnes poussent beaucoup que qu'au
fond on peut être bloquée sur ses
parents sur ces comparons maria grands
parents tout simplement parce qu'on n'a
pas eu la formation de ses proches
alors avant internet tantôt on commence
donc par interrogé ensuite les mairies
et ensuite archives départementales
d'accord justement aujourd'hui est ce
qu'internet favorise ce travail de
recherche est ce que c'est beaucoup plus
facile aujourd'hui
alors depuis le début de l'année des
années 2000 la géologie a été boostée
par internet
maintenant il y à une offre pléthorique
d'outils de toutes sortes de base de
données d'outils sur lequel on peut
déposer serge énergie à partir de là on
peut partager c'est à dire on peut d'une
part découvrir des cousins il est aussi
plus facile de travailler sur une
branche quand on est à plusieurs que
tout seul donc ce partage c'est vraiment
une grande évolution de la jauge est
maintenant il ya des bases de toute
sorte que ce soit sur les militaires
les marins un plus les archives
départementales ont mis les registres en
ligne donc on peut faire sa géologie
quasiment dans son fauteuil pour un
particulier
si on commence une recherche jusqu'où
va-t-on aller on va dire facilement
c'est à dire jusqu'à quelle époque on va
pouvoir avoir des informations
donc en moyenne disons le cursus normal
je dirais c'est milieu du xviie siècle
1650 on peut quelquefois est arrêté sur
une ou quelques manches avant et
quelquefois elle est aussi beaucoup plus
loin pourquoi cette date qu'est ce qui
se passe à peu près à cette époque
rth à peu près la disponibilité des
registres de à cette époque il n'y a pas
des registres disponible pour toutes les
communes tous les départements donc pour
aller plus loin il faut disposer
quelques fois d'autres sources qui
peuvent être des archers notariale des
dispenses de console unité où
effectivement avoir la chance d'être
dans un département ce qu'elle est les
registres on vote plus loin une question
est-ce que même c est ce que ces
registres sont compréhensibles pour pour
la plupart d'entre nous c'est à dire
est-ce qu'on peut retrouver facilement
ces informations les textes sont
disponibles oui les textes sont
disponibles encore faut-il déduire les
interpréter effectivement dans ses
dénégations
au xviie siècle en tout ces 180 il faut
un minimum de connaissances en
paléographie pour interpréter les
registres
qu'est ce que la paléographie et appelé
au gras fils et l'étude de l'écriture
anciennes donc c'est apprendre à lire
les actes anciens c'est ce qu'on fait
dans notre association savons une séance
tous les jeudis où nous apprenons les
nouveaux et aussi les anciens
elle n'a pas l'air graphique et
conscience assez rude assez compliqué
c'est à dire qu'en fait ces documents ne
vois là sont écrits en une langue
ancienne qui est difficilement
compréhensible c'est une culture
totalement différente de l'actuelle
d'accord alors donc des réseaux sociaux
et d'internet pourquoi venir dans un
club de généalogie
pourquoi venir d'un pub de géologie la
plupart des gens qui viennent chez nous
c'est souvent pour apprendre c'est à
dire un souvent ils viennent de partir
la retraite ils ont décidé de commencer
leur géologie pour diverses raisons
et ils veulent apprendre donc justement
notre association a pour vocation
essentielle d'apprendre à faire la
jeunesse joj des actions des formations
nous avons quatre séances par semaine
une séance formation générale le lundi
initiation à l'informatique est un
logiciel le mardi l'initiation à la
paléographie le jeudi et des ateliers
le vendredi non conforme et aussi
quelques personnes qui sont déjà très
féru très avancé un jeune fille qui
s'inscrivent au club tout simplement
pour partager et on a toujours à prendre
d'accord alors à l'occasion donc de
votre trentième anniversaire je rappelle
que va proposer le club racines le 13 et
14 mai prochains dans ce week-end les 13
et 14 mai nous proposons quatre choses
tout d'abord un salon nous aurons 17
exposants
cinq associations locales huit
associations régionales et trois
professionnels
nous organisons également des
conférences moi même je présenterai ce
je présenterai l'association racines
pour les personnes qui connaissent pas
ils rentrent présentation à la
paléographie nous en parlait tout à
l'heure une initiation à la généalogie
est une conférence sur les inscrits
maritimes
je les arts aujourd'hui il y aura aussi
donc des panneaux sur les trente ans et
nos travaux des arbres et surtout un
point très important un salon au fond
c'est à dire nous avons réservé une
salle entière aux enfants pour les
initier de manière ludique à la pole à
la généalogie parfait merci beaucoup
messieurs merci encore c'est la fin de
ce cette fuite les invités pour ce soir
prochain rendez vous demain d'ici là
toutes nos séquences sont en replay sur
l'application tv fil 78 et également sur
le site internet tv fil 78 points comme
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]
ans